[Musique]
11 novembre 1918 à la fin de la première
guerre mondiale
on apprend la mise au point dans le plus
grand secret de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le sonar son histoire
commence quelques années plus tôt par
une tragédie
en avril 1912 le titanic frappe un
iceberg
naufrage fait 1500 morts et met en
lumière un besoin criant celui de
détecter des objets sous l'eau la
première innovation clé est l'oeuvre du
canadien original fessenden à l'époque
on dispose déjà de micro pour écouter
sous l'eau fait sam dance on inspire
pour créer un appareil capable d'émettre
des sons en plus d entendre son
instigateur parvient à capter les kodan
isbergues et permet de calculer sa
distance mais il y a huit majeurs
impossible de savoir dans quelle
direction se trouve
le problème c'est la fréquence du son
son appareil vibreur 540 fois par
seconde ce qui produit note moyenne qui
ratisse trop large avec une fréquence
plus élevée une autre plus aiguë on peut
canaliser leçon et créer un faisceau il
suffit alors d'une pointe et dans
différentes directions pour trouver d'où
vient l'écho de nice baird par exemple
pour cela il faut dépasser ce que
l'oreille peut entendre est entré dans
le domaine des ultrasons dans la
première guerre mondiale éclate la
détection par ultrasons devient une
priorité absolument car on découvre une
nouvelle menace
les sous-marins ceux de l'allemagne vont
hors piller 5000 navires marchands et
200 bâtiments guerre c'est au physicien
français paul langevin qu'on doit la
solution avec son équipe il mit sur un
cristal de quartz une idée qui va
changer le cours de l'histoire
l'émetteur utilisé par paul langevin est
constituée par une lame de quoi un
cristal piézoélectriques c'est à dire
que lorsqu on soumet le quartz un
courant électrique
il se met à vibrer exactement la même
fréquence qu'il courant jusque dans les
ultrasons et quand les corps revient
sous forme de vibrations le quartz les
traduit en courant électrique
c'est à lire autour révèle ce qui se
trouve sous le navire et autour fin 1918
l'appareil de langevin sera le premier à
pouvoir déterminer à la fois la distance
et la direction d'un sous-marin et
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
son invention jouera un rôle clé contre
les eu beau allemand le sonneur a
aujourd'hui une foule d'applications que
ce soit pour la pêche commerciale
l'aide à la navigation ou pour étudier
les fonds marins mais depuis peu on
réalise qu'ils perturbent la vie marine
en particulier celle des balais car si
les océans n'ont jamais été silencieux
l'invention du sonar il ya un siècle
ajoute de plus en plus de fausses notes
à cette mystérieuse symphonie naturel
[Musique]